but uh yeah he has to be ambitious he
has to be responsible he has to be he
has to know the worth of money you know
so how much money
45k
too much too little
it's okay 45k is okay yeah and how tall
does he have to be taller than me for
sure okay so I feel like I'm dating a
Minion Okay and he has to be good
looking too right in shape
he takes care of himself he likes he's a
hygienic like he likes you know to go to
the gym it cannot be like it doesn't
need to be a like a nerd you know like
can you say a gym nerd
yeah yeah I mean but it likes to take
care of himself because I do that too so
we have to have that in common otherwise
I think it would be a little bit
um yeah so guys um how much money does a
girl have to make to date you she could
be in the streets right now
she can be sleeping right there as long
as she's beautiful I will bring her up
I'll I'll bring her into the left yeah
I'll go to the McDonald's
okay so another question how tall does
she have to be any hikes I'm six foot
five so I don't know anyhow for me for
me I'll say above five five actually
yeah I'm tired of giving these five two
girls my like my energy like I'm a king
I can't do it anymore actually to be
honest I love five two girls maybe I
don't know anyhow anyway okay
um how attractive one to ten oh they
have to be fine okay they have to be
fine yeah they have to be
so outside of looks what else oh they
have a good character good character as
in because
if you're dating for like a long time
yeah like marriage or like kids that's
the person that's going to raise your
kids so you could be a 10 but if your
character's dead
like so yeah your character has to be
your character has to be attempt that's
what I mean so I feel like
money-wise I I don't care like I really
don't care what character-wise is more
important yeah I feel like for men you
you fall in what initially attracts you
is obviously their looks and then once
you get to know them oh once you get to
know that you can bring their looks down
yeah and you can also bring them up as
well like it lets you kind of stay with
them but true that's all we really care
about just looks and looks personal yeah
I don't know for me culturally like I
know it's gonna sound in 2022 it sounds
it sounds mad and I know it sounds bad
but the whole cooking thing like a woman
that can't for me culturally because I'm
African African man a woman that can't
cook I'm sorry like I've dated girls and
been like oh yeah I can't cook let's go
take out I'm like
this is not going to go far but okay
like anything is I don't need you to go
I could I can cook we need it together
we can work them but it's just like
culturally
I need someone I can't lie I don't care
if they can't cook I don't care like
don't get taken away no I do they just
need to be very pretty in it and it's
hard to find pretty girls so that's
already like loosening the well shooting
in the pool in it you know it's an
interesting man's foot right on dating
apps around 50 of the time 50 you
actually think it's hard to find pretty
woman out there today
yeah well then you must have a very
specific type yeah I do yeah exactly
that's why you find it why are you
laughing because it definitely yeah
that's the joke what's that what's my
type finds his type he loses his entire
mind
five two five two five two I'll just say
I don't care it's the curly hair and
it's like Middle Eastern
so like a female version of you a little
bit I'm not into these no right now I
like like Middle Easterns
yeah Latinas yeah yeah mixture
but it gotta be fine okay
I'm selective I'm very selective I can't
lie do you feel like most men are
selective no
um most men know my friends yes
yeah yeah
um I think I think my point is though
like like it's just different because in
general like like women have a long list
of [ __ ] that they want and men don't and
like so when they say high value they're
just talking about the men that like
girls want like you don't there's
different studies so I I don't know the
exact number but between like five and
twenty percent of men on dating apps get
all of the likes and some people say
it's as little as five percent they get
eighty percent of the like sorry and
then the the because like most girls
want guys who are like over six foot but
they didn't realize it's actually not
common for guys to be over six foot it's
like they want all these diff specific
categories in this like there's only a
few guys that fit all their needs or
yeah it's like the curse of being tall
as a girl yeah yeah it's like but I like
to be told I wouldn't change I love
being tall too me too but I don't care
if a guy's like close but I I can't if
it's too much I can't do it yeah I can't
I feel you how tall are you uh five
eleven are we the same height 179
well I'm 5 11. I don't know what it is
in centimeters we will check yeah I
didn't I didn't realize you were that
tall I think I'm a bit taller than me
okay yeah
um
okay
um what
have any of you had any crazy cheating
stories or like social media even if
it's just a friend
why are you laughing
what's funny
what's funny okay go ahead he has a few
go ahead like when you say crazy what do
you mean like that that cheating I don't
know just you you know you're laughing
tell the story
know which one
um okay there was one where a friend who
had cheated on his partner quite a lot
um
basically which friend name him
what's an accent in the group watching
um yeah where he went to a house party
after him and his girl got back together
and
he got he loved that girl like he told
us all the time I was like yeah this is
the gun want to marry and then he goes
his house party now
I was with him he was like he was on his
best behavior
and but there was a girl with us and
then they were just like chilling
whatever having having a laugh and then
by the end of the night because
he was waved and then he was like oh
yeah yeah we're gonna get the same cab
home because like she's going in my
direction I'm gonna hop out and then I'm
looking in like big muscle blind to me
just go in the cab man I don't care
you're alive yeah sounds like in the
morning he calls us
and he's like guys I didn't beat it I
didn't beat it he stole the other stuff
but he was so happy with himself they
didn't beat it because like I've changed
I've changed
registered with him that he still
cheated he was like because I'm gonna
change mine I love my girlfriend oh no
way I love her I love her
I'm trying to figure who this is
oh my God he didn't register that he
still cheated on his girlfriend yeah
because that's so awesome
he saw when he saw him turning down
having sex with that girl as like okay
clearly I can't do this anymore I need
to go back to her and he was sorry he
was so excited like when he called us on
the group chat so excited are they still
together oh God no did she find out I'm
actually not sure how it's awesome
tomorrow okay
how many girls did he do that with oh
too many
like more more than you could count
um the ones